non
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire qu'à 150
mille emplois et à 150 mille chômeurs en
plus dans notre profession sur le
premier semestre
j'ai annoncé depuis des mois qui aurait
30 % de faillite d'ici la fin de l'année
et 250 mille chômeurs en plus et je
pense qu'on va y arriver plus vite qu'on
ne le pense
on n'est pas plus dangereux que dans un
avion dans un train que dans une cantine
scolaire que dans une cantine de resto u
c'est pas vrai ici les gens sont
encadrés ont fait respecter les gestes
barrière ya un mètre de distance entre
chaque table les gens se lèvent ils
mettent leurs masques fermer nos
entreprises fermer nos établissements
s'est déplacé le problème c'est aller
vers des manifestations sauvages sur la
voie publique dans les lieux privés ou
aucune règle aucune règles sont
respectées que nous demandons c'est une
baisse des charges
quelle qu'elle soit charges sociales
patronales mais de la tva pour redorer
notre trésorerie les hôtels sont mis à
mal les cafés bars restaurants sont mis
à mal les traiteurs sont à l'arrêt les
discothèques ne touche plus à un euro
depuis six mois maintenant
aujourd'hui le gouvernement de nous dans
tomb et nous aider on a eu un plan de
sauvetage
accompagné par le chômage partiel mais
pas suffisant et aujourd'hui le plan de
relance nous en sommes les apps sur
total tous les sous sont dirigés vers
l'industrie qui sont des emplois qui
sont pourquoi pas délocalisables nous
nous sommes bien ancré sur le territoire
nous représentant deux millions
d'emplois
il faut que l'état prenne conscience que
si nous laisse tomber ses sont autant de
gens qui vont se retrouver sans travail